j'accueille stéphane guillon
bonsoir ou pas
je ne sais
pas stéphane guillon qui vient de
publier un livre dont je n'ai pas le
droit de donner le titre non à cause du
csa stéphane guillon qui est sur scène
tous les soirs j'ai pas le droit de dire
ou non plus à cause de ça en revanche je
suis pas rancunier je vais donner
l'adresse du csa c'est 43 quai andres
[Applaudissements]
allez-y c'est un endroit formidable voix
en bassin très très bon moment voilà
alors stéphane votre revue de préserver
politique on commence par un scoop ce
matin une cassette de ségolène royal
nous est parvenue des images très intime
la madone du ps déguisé en enseignante
s'accouple avec françois hollande
habillant directeur d'école des propos
très crus vas-y françois traite mois de
feignasses fait - rtt j'adore ça
également un poster nous est adressée
attention c'est un collector
madame dsk anne sinclair en tenue sado
maso
dommage que strauss kahn est perdue vous
auriez été tous les soirs à l'elysée
thierry
en revanche le couple le pen jany et
jean-marie sont à la campagne
c'est dans le domaine de la vie privée
des
politiques toujours bernadette chirac
souhaite un troisième mandat pour son
mari vous avez vu comme il est en forme
s'écrie-t-elle c'est vrai hier jacques a
fait un puzzle entier avec jacques
martin et paul loup sulitzer
venu jouer avec lui à l'elysée s'en
remettra
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu est-ce qu on peut voir les
deux photos ensemble bernadette et anne
sinclair
seria pas photo un nom à chaque pièce
jaune un coup de fouet
ça donne envie de cacher cette yaris
société les prisons de la honte titre le
parisien drogue violent bizutage
surpopulation faut pas exagérer ce qui
est surtout dur c'est la télé allumée 24
heures sur 24
tf1 en boucle ça explique le nombre de
suicides
se faire [ __ ] en regardant bataille
et fontaine c'est la double peine
vie pratique une taxe écolo fait flamber
les prix + 13 euros pour un congélateur
conséquence depuis mercredi les
nourrissons sont rangés dans le jardin
attendait ces tirs après c'est toujours
toujours cuit médecine le viagra féminin
disponible dès janvier malheureusement
des effets secondaires sont à craindre
acné et pilosité abondante
si votre femme a de nouveau envie de
vous c'est vous qui n'avez plus envie
d'elle
sport sarkozy a remis la médaille de
bronze à la conductrice du bus incendié
à marseille si elles avaient été brûlés
avec son bus elle aurait été médaille
d'or à ce niveau de la compétition ça se
joue à rien et lloris
devrait être un deuxième et un premier
c'est quoi c'est un coup de boule la
différence
people une info gala paris s'il tonne
d'or dans un lit à 20 mille dollars
quitte à coucher avec une conne autant
que la literie soit top
[Musique]
dans le magazine femme actuelle isabelle
giordano raconte monica bellucci déjà
monica bellucci c'est chiant racontée
par isabelle giordano
on atteint des sommets
[Applaudissements]
dans gala un très beau reportage sur les
années yéyé notamment une photo de mike
brant avec son doberman quand mike a
sauvé par sa fenêtre le chien a suivi
ces cons d'être fidèle
et celle
estelle lefébure propose un calendrier
très coquin pour l'unicef faites vous
une petite douceur tout en aidant les
plus démunis la branlette humanitaire un
nouveau concept
unicef
unicef toujours ce soir tf1 fait les 60
ans de l'organisation
une cérémonie doublée d'une expérience
scientifique pour égaler le coefficient
intellectuel d'une animatrice brune tf1
utilisera les cerveaux de deux
animatrices blonde pour l'occasion 500
petits choristes chanteront aurait été
chouette d'invités michael jackson tous
les mots
chantés avec bambi prendre un enfant par
la main d'yves duteil ça aurait eu de la
gueule à la semaine prochaine merci
beaucoup
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu